[Music]
welcome to happy wheels because let's do
it saina class that would be awesome
sorry sorry keep rotting I don't give a
[ __ ] ah damn start attic keep running
faster did I tell you to stop running
there we go faster you little [ __ ]
[Laughter]
they're always scared you love [ __ ] look
Yolo all right time you know I love you
[ __ ] no okay go did something someone
say something oh it's raining oh that's
so nice
I love the rain oh [ __ ] what was that
what happened damn it you're like a
herpes you won't go away come on got my
needs on oh I can still touch his wiener
fly
grab the spacebar I wonder why this egg
is kinda dry fly under wings
Wow Wow close enough
all right another [ __ ] PewDiePie quiz
because happy wheels needs more of this
pity prize real ladies whoa this is
legit okay
my real name is a temp his name means
happy and Latin who the [ __ ] does that
but that's a good tip all right it's
Felix white which game did PewDiePie
play in his first video tablet I already
use that presented they all disappeared
minecraft where I was pretty bored I
jump god dammit Gothenburg ran with food
fight born as a chopper funny what I
know when I'm born you [ __ ] battle oh
oh it's my bad
whose piggies his feet by his mortal
enemy tip there's no tip his mortal
enemy carries vine that's one thing I
don't even know that [ __ ] well shift
which of its videos is most popular oh
[ __ ] Oh percentage why do they all
disappear 50/50 come on Russ shift yes
rich beautifies mom it's awkward I'll
talk about my mom yeah ivote for a
Tobuscus don't fall
hell yeah this is a small step for me
but the giant step for the mecha
industry yeah is how I walk every day
you think I how do you hell do you think
I got a hot girlfriend geez
can I shake your hand very nice to meet
you hi what's your response you wanna
make out
come here nailed it there we go alright
impossible
Hartford will see how impossible if you
finish right if I start gum wet well
that was so impossible welcome to John
just jump jumping is for business oh
okay well I would bet it this is what
happens when you twerk your little [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] just happened that front
flip though hell yeah
field sir I feel different this isn't
even my final form okay I'll do it
what did I break happy wheels I'm
talking to your genitals right now but I
want you to make me proud and finish
this race I don't care if there's a
vagina in there
actually it'd serve a giant in there
anyway go make me proud you little [ __ ]
okay I'll try okay I'll wait here gosh
odd
Elna hobo but what how kill the hobo
grab that sword shove it up my ass
yes now that [ __ ] I can see the galaxy
from here oh wait that's my answer
okay third million times oh nice nice
I'll show you how it's done mother
[ __ ] you don't need no legs to ride a
bus okay baby you do [ __ ] well I can
still dance
you can never take away this fabulous
dance god damn it bike what are you
doing get out of my face all right fine
I'll ride you
let's go why aren't you working
why aren't you working I'm doing my
dance I'm doing my dance for your what I
wanna be a bus roughest toughest
toughest I wanna be the bear now that
that's how a dunking switch Oh
Jerry I didn't know you felt this way
about me Jerry I love you too Johnny
[Music]
arms oh no my arms are living that's
fine this is how you twerk and happy
wheels all right what is this watch okay
I have a tail yes you have to live the
rest of your life with one arm [ __ ] how
dare you how does that feel well I'm
offended press see oh okay
shag kill shame Kim I'll show you a
shame you [ __ ]
this is what I call us why do I have
this voice okay this is not a shame Cuba
all right son let's [ __ ] do this
oh that tickled my [ __ ] up up Jesus
Christ I have the ass of Nicki Minaj oh
my god you're merging with my [ __ ]
my son is becoming my ass is amazing
[ __ ] power
fall pop god damn it that's not what I
wanted son Elvis
that's what I wanted you went inside all
right you little [ __ ] let's see if we
can do this
Oh still dancin still dancin um god damn
it why are you eating me you [ __ ] I just
want to save you tastes good how was it
tastes like [ __ ] Oh all right boy whoa
holy [ __ ] done nearly got us oh well
better luck next time
ah god damn it harpoon you mess
there ya go that's better that son of a
[ __ ] got me right in the throat I'm
buddy even speaking right now
doesn't matter must finish this level
for my son actually actually no I don't
give a [ __ ] about him whatever
front-flip say I don't even need to do
flips through the front flips
it's not all you got it's at all your
god pet oh well that feels nice in my
ass all right brother I hope you enjoyed
this episode if you did go ahead and
leave me like it helps me out a lot and
subscribe to become a bread today
[Music]
- this entire babbling and holy [ __ ] I
got arrows in my ax
[Music]